let's get the latest analysis of the
situation on the ground in Ukraine
joining me now is the defense and
security analyst Michael Clarke Michael
thanks for joining us let's take a look
at the map and let's look at this area
around Kiev what do you make of the
Russian withdrawal as it appears to be
from that area yes I mean the Russians
have said that it's a strategic
withdrawal but it's a defeat By Any
Other Name they can't disguise that fact
they've pulled out of of Northwest and
Northeast Kiev they've gone back to the
Belarusian border the ukrainians have
driven them out but also moved into the
areas they've vacated they're the
ukrainians are even appropriate we were
looking at a big pontoon Bridge before
The Invasion started appropriate and
that's now back in Ukrainian hands and I
was looking earlier on this morning at
all of the equipment that had been lost
the the latest figures show that the
Russians seem to have lost about three
or four times the amount of equipment of
the ukrainians so they are defeated in
Kiev for the time being that's pretty
clear but if we move further eastwards
and have a look look at the situation
there
the area around the Don bass of course
this is the area where the invasion
first started can we expect Russian
forces from the areas we've been talking
about to now redeploy down here yes I
mean the forces are pulled out of Kiev
that area have gone back to Belarus to
re-equip and recover which they
certainly need but more forces that are
being formed another 10 Battalion
tactical groups it seems will be going
to the southeast and the area of the
donbass which is the the black edged
area there
um is the area now being fought over as
you've just put the symbol around it the
Russians occupied about a third of those
that donbass region before the war they
now occupy about half of it it looks as
if they'll try to take the whole of the
donbass region and consolidate this land
bridge through to Crimea but it'll be
pretty tough for them because the best
of the Ukrainian forces are down there
they've been dug in for eight years
they're well dug in and the weather I've
been looking at the weather this morning
in Ukraine the weather is warming up
quite dramatically this week by the end
end of the week it will be around 20
degrees and Rain the ground is getting
softer as the spring comes on and if the
Russians think they're going to move
their armored forces around in a quick
Battle of maneuver in the Southeast
they'll find that quite difficult
because the ground is getting soft and
what about the situation further down
near where you are down there in Odessa
um Russian advances still on there and
still trying to attack Odessa yes the
Russians have hit a number of targets
around Odessa mainly oil storage
facilities that's a sensible military
objective because the old storage round
of deaths are very important port was
feeding Ukrainian armies Ukrainian
forces elsewhere so to try and block off
the oil storage and oil supply makes
perfect military sense but also the
Russians seem to be trying to harm the
infrastructure of Ukraine because part
of the objective is to damage Ukraine as
much as possible as this war goes on and
I think what we've seen in Odessa is not
an attempt really to invade a death
which we thought would be on the cards a
couple of weeks ago but just to hurt it